انا من البدايه عارف انه هاي البطوله
مخبيه لها شيء كبير بلا شك شي كبير نحن مش
عم نحلم منتخب عربي في ربع نهائي كاس
العالم هذا ليس حلما نحن لا نحلم هذه
حقيقه المغرب في ربع نهائي كاس العالم
2022 اول منتخب عربي في ربع نهائي كاس
العالم ثاني او ثالث منتخب افريقي يصل الى
ربع نهائي كاس العالم وعالمين على بطره
العالم 2010 اسبانيا اسبانيا بنجوم
برشلونه وريال مدريد تخسر امام المغرب
امام رجال المغرب امام ابطال المغرب امام
الذين صنعوا التاريخ اليوم هنا في ملعب
المدينه التعليميه هذا الملعب اللي ورائي
مش ملعب عادي هذا ما راح يكون ملعب عادي
حتى بعد نهايه كاس العالم هذا الصرح
تاريخي لكل انسان مغربي وعربي متابع لكره
القدم المغرب في ربع النهائي بالفعل بعد
مباراه بطوليه بطوليه بطوليه بطوليه امام
المنتخب الاسباني بعد اداء رجولي اداء
الابطال كيف تمكن من الفوز على اسبانيا رح
تكتيكات بسيطه جدا ما راح نعقد الامور لان
اليوم من الاحتفالات اليوم للفرحه اليوم
كلنا مغاربه كل انسان عربي هو مغربي اليوم
من كل دول الادمن كل الدول العربيه الكل
يهنئ المغرب اليوم الكل المغربي اليوم
الكل المغربي الهوى والهويه اليوم وليد
الاراك يقرا المباراه بالشكل الصحيح مائه
بالمئه سكر على مفاتيح لاعب المنتخب
الاسباني اللي هم كافي وبدري ونجحوا املاح
وامناحي بينهم يمنعوا الكره تصل بالشوط
الاول للبدري بشكل تام في عدنان سوري كان
عامل اوفر شادو مسكر الخطوط التمرير على
بوس كيدز لذلك المنتخب الاسباني يلعب كره
طوليه لا اسينسيو بالشوط الاول ماشي
بواحده منها ولكنها ضيعها ما عدا ذلك كانت
مقطوعه والكهرباء في شوط المباراه الاول
المغرب عامل ثلاث فرص على اسبانيا مقابل
فرصه واحده للمنتخب الاسباني تخيل المغرب
كانت افضل بمراحل في شوط المباراه الاول
في شوط المباراه الثاني مدرب المغرب صح
عادل صح دفعه بالدفاع متاخر وترك الكره
للاسبان العبوا براحتكم اعملوا ما شئتم
بالكره لن تسجلوا لانه دفاع المغرب حاضر
دفاع المغرب قوي ودفاع المغرب منظم وهذا
ما حدث بالفعل اسبانيا لم تسجل وذهبت
لمباراه الاشواط الاضافيه بالاشواط
الاضافيه سلكت المباراه مشت بالشكل
المطلوب مع المنتخب المغربي كما اراد
وبركلات الترجيح ابطال المغرب فعلوها
ونجحوا بالوصول الى ربع النهائي كاس
العالم لاول مره في تاريخ الدول العربيه
مرحله اليوم كل هذا الشباب حبيبي اول حاجه
الكلمه لهذه الناس هذه حبيبي اهل قطر
والله العظيم
بين اليوم بين اليوم على الانسحاب الدول
العربيه كلها انسحب البلد
جزاك الله خير يا شيخ امين جزاك الله يا
شيخ سمير
العرب كلهم هنا وان شاء الله نجمعهم في
الدول العربيه وشكرا على اهل قطر شكرا
الشعوب العربيه اللي عايشه في بلد قطر
شكرا والف شكر وان شاء الله القادم افضل
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]